you did one of my favorite movies and I
loved your part if I'm right
Warrior oh yeah you were the trainer
yeah brother trainer I was young you
were so awesome thanks Joe edgerton's
trainer an unknown Joe Edgerton an
unknown Tom Hardy yeah that is another
movie
that reviews are off the hook it's
people that when they see it they're
like how have you not seen words I know
it's a movie that's great yeah it caught
a life well after they didn't Market it
they didn't know how to Market it it was
Tom Hardy and Joel on a poster and said
hey man it looked like a fight poster
and MMA wasn't really mainstream right
at that time yeah really like Dana White
hates that movie
hates it why because she feels like it's
not a good representation of Fighters
and and he I did a show a TV series
called kingdom yes
um he came to the set he loved that
because we kind of made that real we
kind of made it you know like the UFC
but he hated he Dana White hates Warrior
is it because it just was kind of flashy
and because I thought it was both